kim kardashian is ready for the next
chapter of her life a source tells et
that the reality star feels like quote
there is a weight lifted off her
shoulders after officially filing for
divorce from kanye west
last friday e.t source says that the
split has been in the works for a while
now
adding that the reality star spent time
with her family in palm springs
california
after filing quote kim feels like she
can put that part behind her and start
to move forward in healing
kim knows she will be okay it's just
going to take some time to get used to
her new normal
at the end of the day life is about
being happy on monday kim took to her
insta story to share
this video from the car window the song
she selected
olivia rodrigo's heartbreak anthem track
driver's license you're tired
of hearing how much i miss
the ballad played out over three posts
to her story
and on the final post the kkw beauty
founder added a series of
white green brown and black hearts
book ended by knife emojis
[Music]
kim filed for divorce from kanye on
friday after six years of marriage
she is asking for joint legal and
physical custody of their four children
they share
seven-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago and one-year-old
psalm
a source told et at the time that the
rapper is fine with the joint custody
agreement
and that the two are committed to
co-parenting together
i think our kids will see you know kanye
and i work really hard
and i hope that's motivating for them
and just to find their own path
on friday the 40 year old reality star
honored her late father
robert kardashian on his birthday
writing quote i celebrate you
every single day but today even more
kim added that she's been eager to talk
to her dad writing
so much to tell you and making this
request
please come visit me in a dream soon
you